Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Cada año el mundo consume
35 mil millones de barriles de petróleo.
Esta escala masiva de dependencia de
combustibles fósiles contamina la Tierra
y no durará para siempre.
Los científicos estiman
que ya se ha consumido
alrededor del 40 % del petróleo del mundo.
De acuerdo con las estimaciones actuales,
a ese ritmo,
nos quedaremos sin petróleo
y gas en 50 años más o menos,
y en aproximadamente
un siglo también sin carbón.
Por otro lado, tenemos
abundante sol, agua y viento.
Estas son fuentes de energía renovables,
lo que significa que no
los acabaremos con el tiempo.
¿Qué pasaría si sustituyéramos nuestra
dependencia de combustibles fósiles
por una existencia basada
únicamente en energías renovables?
Hemos reflexionado sobre
esa pregunta durante décadas,
y, sin embargo, la energía renovable solo
proporciona el 13 %
de nuestras necesidades.
Eso es porque alcanzar el 100 %
requiere energía renovable
que sea económica y accesible.
Esto representa un gran desafío, incluso
si ignoramos la política involucrada
y nos enfocamos
en la ciencia y la ingeniería.
Podemos entender mejor el problema
al entender cómo usamos la energía.
El uso de energía global es
un sistema diverso y complejo,
y los diferentes elementos
requieren sus propias soluciones.
Pero por ahora, nos centraremos en dos de
los más familiares en la vida cotidiana:
la electricidad y
los combustibles líquidos.
La electricidad alimenta los altos
hornos, ascensores, computadoras
y todo tipo de cosas en hogares,
negocios y manufactura.
Mientras tanto, los combustibles líquidos
juegan un papel crucial
en casi todas las formas de transporte.
Consideremos primero la parte eléctrica.
La gran noticia es que nuestra tecnología
ya es lo suficientemente avanzada
para capturar toda esa energía
de las energías renovables,
y hay una amplia oferta.
El Sol continuamente irradia
alrededor de 173 cuatrillones
de vatios de energía solar a la Tierra,
que es casi 10 000 veces
nuestras necesidades actuales.
Se ha estimado que una superficie que
abarcara varios cientos de miles de km
sería necesaria para alimentar a la
humanidad en los niveles actuales de uso.
Entonces, ¿por qué no construimos eso?
Porque hay otros obstáculos en el camino,
como la eficiencia
y el transporte de energía.
Para maximizar la eficiencia,
las plantas solares deben ubicarse en
áreas de mucho sol durante todo el año,
como los desiertos.
Pero esos están muy lejos
de las regiones densamente pobladas
donde la demanda de energía es alta.
Hay otras formas de energía renovable
de las que nos podríamos abastecer,
como la hidroeléctrica,
geotérmica
y biomasas,
pero también tienen límites en función
de la disponibilidad y la ubicación.
En principio,
una red de energía eléctrica conectada
con líneas eléctricas cruzando el mundo
nos permitiría transportar
energía desde donde se genera
a donde se necesita.
Pero construir un sistema en esta escala
enfrenta un precio astronómico.
Podríamos reducir el costo mediante
el desarrollo de tecnologías avanzadas
para capturar energía
de manera más eficiente.
La infraestructura para transportar
energía debería cambiar drásticamente.
Las líneas eléctricas actuales pierden
del 6-8 % de la energía que llevan
porque el material de alambre derrocha
la energía por la resistencia.
Las líneas eléctricas más largas
significarían más derroche de energía.
Los superconductores
podrían ser una solución.
Dichos materiales pueden
transportar electricidad sin derroche.
Desafortunadamente, solo funcionan
si se enfrían a bajas temperaturas,
lo que requiere energía y
frustra el objetivo.
Para beneficiarse de esa tecnología,
tendríamos que descubrir
nuevos materiales superconductores
que operan a temperatura ambiente.
¿Y los importantísimos combustibles
líquidos derivados del petróleo?
El desafío científico es
almacenar energía renovable
de forma fácilmente transportable.
Recientemente se ha mejorado la
producción de baterías de iones de litio,
que son livianas y
tienen densidad de alta energía.
Pero incluso las mejores almacenan
alrededor de 2.5 megajulios por kg.
Eso es aproximadamente 20 veces menos
que la energía en un kg de gasolina.
Para ser verdaderamente competitivas,
las baterías de los automóviles
tendrían que almacenar
mucha más energía sin agregar costo.
Los desafíos solo aumentan para
naves más grandes, como barcos y aviones.
Para impulsar un vuelo
a través del Atlántico para un jet,
necesitaríamos una batería
que pesa alrededor de 1 000 toneladas.
Esto también exige un salto tecnológico
hacia nuevos materiales,
mayor densidad de energía,
y mejor almacenamiento.
Una solución prometedora
sería encontrar formas eficientes
para convertir energía solar
en energía química.
Esto ya está sucediendo
en los laboratorios,
pero la eficiencia es aún demasiado baja
para permitir que llegue al mercado.
Para encontrar soluciones novedosas,
necesitaremos mucha creatividad,
innovación,
y poderosos incentivos.
La transición hacia energías totalmente
renovables es un problema complejo
que involucra tecnología,
economía y política.
La prioridad de cómo abordar este desafío
depende de suposiciones específicas
que tenemos que hacer, al tratar de
resolver un problema tan multifacético.
Pero hay muchas razones
para ser optimistas de lograrlo.
Las mentes científicas más importantes
del mundo están trabajando en ello
y realizan avances todo el tiempo.
Y muchos gobiernos y empresas
están invirtiendo en tecnologías
que aprovechan
la energía a nuestro alrededor.